Johnny Bench had 10 Gold Gloves I think
he's the greatest defensive catcher of
all time but maybe I'm a little biased
and Johnny sent us a tweet saying this
is how he displays his he's got his 10
Gold Gloves in his hometown of Binger
Oklahoma and Johnny Bench joining us now
hi Johnny how are you today I've been
watching I mean anything about something
because it seriously considering the
theme of the show today I and we didn't
have football and then you're Oklahoma
but I was thinking about quarterbacks
that are under six one that's only over
aligned them that are six seven and I
think completely dizzy this down and
then wind up with a touchdown okay all
right I got it message sent their
message sent thing up and your croquis
taste there I mean that was a good dish
okay I don't have any Academy Awards I
do have some broadcasting Awards but
those are down in the basement cuz and
they well the sports enemies I just put
in the man cave just to let the Danette
see and touch greatness but you know I
don't want to rub it in no I mean it's
just a frivolous thing yeah I mean I
know they're not gold or platinum or
something of you know your worth but at
the same time I really feel like you
know hey it's a symbol of what you do I
mean you know what an impeach okay they
say NDP national they've got it
you know what does it did it
spray-painted okay but Johnny when you
saw those Gold Gloves in all it is is a
catcher's mitt that was spray-painted
gold like it it lost a little bit of the
wow that's a Gold Glove it feels like
your kids could have made that for you
well the worst thing of all Dennis when
those prongs or three-prong here holding
up the baseball yeah and they break or
they call em hey I broke those you know
a circle crawling eye candy yeah well I
don't know if we have any fun where's
your repairs and everything where's your
MVP
and bender Oklahoma Oh everything is
there in there yeah I have a lot of
stuff stolen and the safety deposit box
one basket was signed by the entire all
century team and I have that and I know
some things there when I've got a couple
of things down here I'm playing you know
it's a reboot bill today they wanted to
build this vision my buddy and Janet
Britton that just started issues will
superintendent of schools and they got
more bad so I think there's a decree
bats of his own and they're quite the
collectors but when we opened this
museum you know we talked about it
everything else about having museum and
Binger and we think that we'll draw 10
to 12 more people a year
do you have any sign Pete Rose
memorabilia Jersey area I don't think I
was bad I had balls eyeballs and turkeys
yeah sure and Joe and Tony I mean I've
got one on display where I've got the
outfield position it's on the wall
plaque on the wall and it's got the
places where an outfield and infield
where you lay all the balls are signed
by the players who played that position
well that's cool
I've been railing on this new modern
baseball philosophy where it's okay to
strike out and nobody puts the ball in
play and now we're watching the Red Sox
do this the Astros did it last year I
don't I hope it's gonna catch on where
you know there's nothing wrong with
moving the runner over or a hit-and-run
or just sort of the smaller things here
because it creates movement and I also
think that you know with two outs we've
seen the Red Sox be so great what do
what have you noticed about the way they
play they're not relying on the home run
and everybody relies on the home run
nowadays well I think maybe the old days
home runs you want to get some money on
contract now now with what we've got
with all those statcast and all the
stuff and everything else people feel
they're worth by what the numbers that
you know everybody's going you go to
stat cast and you find out everything
well I mean there's research being done
they asked was were so successful at it
a lot of other teams they do use these
things and they're showing these things
and you know they're able to display
these things as an agent can to to
owners and right now I mean
you know I know guys would like to make
30 million a year but there you know
these guys that are in the middle and
dealers and everything else are getting
their 12 15 18 million dollars and then
finding out that you know if they played
the game and everybody else they'll get
paid a lot of money and they're into it
I mean and you get it and you're going
to managers couple of managers anyway
like they have and Porras got these guys
believing that this is the way it's
going to believe and you got it and when
you have that mindset first of all you
establish that mindset second of all if
they don't fall into it you find
somebody else that will and that's the
way that they received it to so many
years or finding players that could come
off the bench to do a lot of things but
these guys are buying into it and they I
think what they have curious to start
out some hits I mean I mean that's an
incredible number and you can see why
this was successful in life these are
two great teams I mean as far as young
players dynamic great citizens and
everything else and when I when I told
hit the all-star game the real stud
Wallace had such as jay-z man I mean he
is the man that I won't call it about it
much in the I'm the MVP but he's all
it's all types all five all categories
and the only one in the top five and of
course the votes over so it really
doesn't mean anything really guy said
for eight years but JD is I leave you
with this you know the Dodgers with
sitting left and could you imagine if
you're some of your best players didn't
you know hit well against left-handers
or if you had to sit some guys down
during a World Series game like a guy I
know it's the new data and analytics
here but what do you think of the you
know what Dave Roberts is doing sitting
down these three left or left these
including you know Bellinger and Muncie
and Muncie's you know he gets his pitch
he's a monster but you know and and
again you go towards the last week and
they go towards playoffs and what
they're doing you look at their batting
errors and what their numbers are but I
just you know I just have to you know he
sees in day to day he's told he pulled
all the strings the last six weeks of
the season you know and and made them
into a winner and
they I mean he's got so many he can
interchange so many of these guys out
there on the field
pretty amazing team but yeah it's kinda
hard for me to take fellas a couple
these guys out of the line I don't care
you know how they're matching up but you
know against Chris Sale you've got to
take at least an opportunity to switch
over to the right side and take a chance
with it but yeah it's it's the Dodger is
going to be happy everybody's going to
be happy to get out to a little warmer
level I think sir is going to continuing
because good to visit with you is always
Johnny thank you for the phone call
thank you buddy it's Johnny Bench for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]